By now, we've seen a ton of different kinds of functions in this course. We've
seen polynomial functions, absolute value functions, square root functions and
our piecewise functions, too. One thing we haven't looked at though is
functions that involve division of polynomials, functions that have fractions
in them. What kind of equation would a function like that have? Well, here are
a few examples. All of the functions I've written here involve taking ratios of
polynomials. In other words, dividing one polynomial by another. Remember, that
even constant terms are considered polynomials, too. We call them rational
functions because they are ratios. There's a ton of variety in this family of
functions, and their graphs might not look quite like you expect. So, here are
the graphs of the four functions that I listed up here. But now they are in a
different order. Figure out which function each of these graphs represents and
then write the letter of the graph next to the proper function. I know that
we've never actually seen rational functions before, so to guess what each of
these look like, you can plug in some different points and then see which of
the graphs they fit.